die erste Frage an Robert Habeck die
häufigste Überschrift nach diesem
Koalitionsausschuss Herr Habeck lautet
habecks gasheizungsverbot gekippt welche
Überschrift hören sie denn wählen
dass die erneuerbaren Energien in den
Wärmebereich kommen ich habe die
Überschrift noch nicht gesehen aber das
natürlich falsch also das was ist falsch
daran das gasheizungsverbot besteht
weiterhin
nein wir sind darin überein wir schon
vor einem Jahr entschieden dass wir ab
nächstem Jahr den Einbau von weiteren Öl
und Gasheizungen nicht wollen und dann
gibt es sehr viel Ausdifferenzierung die
Waren im Gesetz schon angelegt
Übergangsfristen Befreiung
technologieoffenheit hier davor schon da
war also biogene Kraftstoffe das Heizen
mit Holz auch Einsatz von Wasserstoff
der im Moment noch nicht verfügbar ist
das war alles schon vorgesehen das ist
jetzt ein bisschen mehr konkretisiert
und ausformuliert worden das ist auch
gut voneinander zu lernen und die
öffentliche Debatte ist natürlich auch
eingeflossen in die Diskussion und die
ist noch nicht zu Ende das ist ja noch
ein längeres Verfahren jetzt bis wir das
zum Sommer durchbekommen aber wir werden
nicht weiter mit fossilen Energien
heizen außer in ganz wenigen
Ausnahmefällen also darf ich noch mal
nachfragen was heißt das jetzt haben wir
das richtig verstanden Gas und
Ölheizungen im Bestand müssen jetzt
nicht zu einem bestimmten Datum
ausgetauscht werden was heißt das nur im
Neubau an welcher Stelle wen wird das
betreffen
also Gas und Ölheizung im Bestand müssen
jetzt schon ausgetauscht werden nach 30
Jahren außer bei selbstgenutzten
Wohneigentum das ist die bestehende
Regel der Unterschied ist jetzt wenn sie
ausgetauscht werden müssen kann man
jetzt die alten Gasheizung gegen neue
oder Gasthermen gegen neue austauschen
das kann man dann danach nicht weil aber
natürlich die Anschaffung erst einmal
wenn es beispielsweise eine Wärmepumpe
ist teurer ist werden wir dort weitere
Befreiung vornehmen also
ältere Damen und Herren die vielleicht
sagen das ist ein Investition die ich
nicht stemmen kann oder will die werden
wie wir von dieser Pflicht nach 30
Jahren austauschen zu müssen befreien
so dass also dieses diese Regelung
flexibel gehandelt oder flexibler
gehandhabt wird aber es bleibt dabei so
ist es jetzt geeint worden dass wir
nicht weiter Öl und Gasheizung einbauen
in der Regel und
das ist auch dringend erforderlich wir
sind eher zu spät daran ich darf
vielleicht einmal daran erinnern Herr
Lanz dass andere Länder früher
angefangen haben so was zu tun ich war
kürzlich ein Dänemark der Anteil an
fossilen Energien also Öl und Gas im
Wärmesystem in Dänemark beträgt noch
bummelig 20 Prozent nun ist Dänemark
nicht dafür berühmt deutlich wärmer als
Deutschland zu sein auch der Bestand der
Gebäude umgespricht entspricht ungefähr
dem deutschen Markt der deutsche Anteil
an fossile Energie beträgt 80%. genau
was ist passiert die denen haben halt
viel früher angefangen zu sagen das ist
eine Kostenfalle für die Verbraucher und
die Verbraucher und es ist eine
abhängigkeitsfalle für das Land also
denken etwas anderes aus okay das
Problem in Deutschland ist und das ist
irgendwie der Fluch meine Amtszeit alles
ist über Jahre Jahrzehnte verbummelt
worden und jetzt müssen wir diese
Bundesregierung und auch mein
Ministerium und ich in
wenig Zeit
das versuchen einzuholen was andere
Länder in Jahren schon gemacht haben
aber es hilft ja nichts da das Problem
einfach nur zu bestaunen also der
Koalitionsausschuss hat gesagt wir
schreiten voran die Vereinbarungen die
bisher auf Arbeits- und
staatssekretärsebene getroffen worden da
sind auch Veränderungen dabei die sind
finden unsere Unterstützung und jetzt
gehen wir als nächsten Schritt in die
Länder und Verbände Anhörung nochmal
Hinweise geben dann wird daraus ein
Gesetz gemacht dann wird es im April
verabschiedet im Kabinett und dann vor
Ostern im Deutschen Bundestag so der
Plan okay ich gebe zu ich habe es noch
nicht verstanden Frau Herrmann haben sie
es verstanden was haben sie nicht
verstanden
auch bei Wärmepumpen müssen Sie uns
helfen das machen Frage erstmal Ulrike
Herrmann wir haben sie das verstanden es
gab Tage lang Wochen lang große
Schlagzeilen zu diesem Thema und immer
war das Schlagwort Robert Habeck und
sein Verbot von Gas und Ölheizungen ab
2024 und deswegen war auch die Aufregung
so groß Menschen hatten das Gefühl ich
muss jetzt meine alte oder auch neue
gerade installierte Öl und Gasheizung
austauschen wo sie rauswerfen und kann
das möglicherweise gar nicht leisten
weil der Einbau einer Wärmepumpe
natürlich vergleichsweise teuer ist wie
haben sie es verstanden und was ist
heute beschlossen worden also ich glaube
das war noch nie der Plan dass man
Gas und Ölheizungen einfach austauscht
egal wie alt Sie sind das hat ja auch
schon erklärt es geht jetzt nicht darum
laufende Heizungen die noch ihre Zeit
vor sich haben auszutauschen sondern es
ging immer um die Frage was passiert mit
neuen Heizungen die man neu installieren
muss weil die alten zu alt sind und da
war eben klar dass man eigentlich weg
muss von fossilen Öl und Gas und ich
glaube das jetzt eigentlich nicht
wesentlich was neues beschlossen worden
ist sondern das gleiche wieder
allerdings muss man sagen dass und da
kann er habe vielleicht noch ein
bisschen mehr zu sagen es ist
außerordentlich wage das Papier da dann
es wird gesagt es gibt einen sozialen
Ausgleich es steht aber nicht drin wie
dieser soziale Ausgleich aussehen soll
das wäre aber zentral weil natürlich es
zwei Möglichkeiten gibt entweder man
unterstützt die Bedürftigen oder man
unterstützt alle nach dem Motto
Gießkanne und am Ende kriegt der
willenbesitzer mehr als die Arme Oma um
es jetzt mal ein bisschen zuzuspitzen
und da muss ich ganz deutlich sagen ich
wäre absolut gegen das Prinzip Gießkanne
nach dem Motto jeder wird gefördert egal
ob es braucht oder nicht und da müsste
ich jetzt gerne einfach nach einer
Arbeit wieder soziale Ausgleich aussehen
soll denn das steht nicht im Papier
jedenfalls nicht in den 16 Seiten die
wir gelesen haben da reden wir sofort
darüber wird aber trotzdem vorher noch
mal gerne Robin Alexander fragen warum
dann diese ganze Aufregungen in den
vergangenen Wochen wir haben sie es
verstanden und was ist heute
rausgekommen
also Herr Habeck hat heute ein Sieg
errungen den er allerdings schon zweimal
errungen hat weil die Vereinbarung
wegzukommen von den Öl- und Gasheizungen
stand schon im Koalitionsvertrag und vor
einem Jahr in einem Koalitionsausschuss
wurde vereinbart das vorzuziehen also
wenn man es freundlich sagen will kann
man sagen er hat die Front gehalten und
die Angriffe waren ja auch stürmisch das
meine ich aber wie vorher man schon sagt
ich meine das ist das Papier und das ist
der Absatz über den wir gerade reden und
das war schon mit den 30 Jahren habe ich
jetzt mal so gescannt das steht ja auch
nicht drin was er habe gesagt hat also
wenn es weitere Vereinbarung gibt auf
staatsse geht erst Ebene dann muss habe
sich darauf verlassen dass die FDP
diesmal auch dazu steht
so das geht mir doch direkt erklären Sie
uns doch einmal bitte
also erstmal ist es ja eine Widerlegung
dass die Papiere also dieses
schlusspapier so detailreich ist und das
so detailreich sein muss wenn man sich
nicht traut sondern das ist richtig wie
es Frau Hermann und Alexander
geschrieben haben das Papier ist nicht
nur an der Stelle aber auch an der
Stelle politisch also es beschreibt den
Prozess wo wir stehen und die das
Commitment die die Verbindlichkeit die
wir damit verbinden aber es geht jetzt
nicht in die Paragraphen Tiefe des
Gesetzes rein und sagt hinter der Ziffer
I macht mir noch eine Ziffer 11 dieser
die Ausnahme wird dann und dann so aber
nur bei dem Teil hier machen ja es gibt
andere es gibt andere Teile klar aber
man muss ja auch verstehen dass man da
hingeschrieben hat hier ist es so dass
wir natürlich weitergearbeitet haben die
Regierung in den letzten Wochen seitdem
das Gesetz in der Öffentlichkeit
diskutiert wird und die verschiedenen
Vorschläge Kritikpunkte
verbesserungsoptionen die die
Koalitionspartner anmelden werden alle
festgehalten und dann zunächst auf
Arbeitsebene dann zunehmend auf
politischer Ebene miteinander geeint und
das heute passiert ist ist dass wir
gesagt haben die geeinten Punkte und das
sind im Grunde alle die halten wir jetzt
fest und mit diesen gehen wir jetzt
weiter und was ist dabei passiert bei
den geeinten Punkten also um es mal in
anderen ein Beispiel zu verdeutlichen
und dann bin ich noch Zeit habe komme
ich zu der sozialen Frage
ich persönlich glaube nicht dass wir in
den nächsten Jahren sehr viel
Wasserstoff haben werden die Option war
schon davor da also wenn Wasserstoff
produziert werden kann und der in der
Gasheizung verbrannt werden kann und der
ist klimaneutral allermeur es geht ja
darum erneuerbare Energien also
dekarbonisierte
Energieträger zu haben wo immer sie
herkommen mich da ist kein Fetischismus
für Wärmepumpen da drin nur die sind
verfügbar und die funktionieren und
Wasserstoff ist im Moment noch nicht
verfügbar und ich befürchte den den wir
produzieren werden den saugt die
Industrie auf oder die die
schwerlastverkehre was auch immer aber
bitte wer also wenn ein Gebäude Besitzer
oder ein Stadtwerk sagt wir machen das
mit Wasserstoff
dann haben wir allerdings geklärt was
ist eigentlich wenn nicht wenn er nicht
da ist man hat die Gastherme und auf
einmal kommt der Wasserstoff nicht wir
wer hat denn eigentlich die
Verantwortung und solche Punkte sind
dann festgehalten worden teilweise
ausgeweitet worden die Übergangsfristen
sind noch mal verlängert worden das ist
sozusagen sehr detailreich auf vielen
Seiten festgehalten jetzt gehen wir
damit in eine sogenannte Verbände
Anhörung die handwerksverbände die
kommunalen Spitzenverbände die Bau und
wohnwirtschaft werden das noch mal alles
kommentieren dann wird wieder die
nächste Korrekturschleife draußen dann
wird es im Kabinett beschlossen dann
macht der Bundestag das gleiche noch mal
und dann sind wir von den Sommerferien
fertig also insofern es ist es geht hier
gar nicht um Sieg oder Niederlage was
passiert ja insgesamt ist dass wir mit
im
Wohnungsbereich und im Verkehrsbereich
bei den beiden großen Streitpunkten der
Koalition sehr dicht an das individuelle
Leben der Menschen dran Rücken das ist
ja
das ist doch jedem einsichtig mir
jedenfalls dass das zu Debatten führt
das macht ja einen großen politischen
Unterschied ob ich sage wir werden die
Stahlproduktion dekarbonisieren und dann
muss ich mit vier Stahlwerken in
Deutschland reden und den CEOs oder ob
wir sagen die der Verkehrssektor wird
die karbonisiert oder die Heizung dann
musst du mit im Grunde mit 80 Millionen
Menschen verhandeln und es gibt
wahrscheinlich auch ungefähr 80
Millionen unterschiedliche Fälle dass da
die debattenlage viel schwieriger ist
und auch die interessenvertretungslage
viel aufgehüter ist so das ist ja
logisch das einzige worauf ich Hinweise
ist nur weil es noch nie gemacht wurde
und alle immer nur gesagt haben wir
werden Klima neutral 2045 ohne zu
handeln heißt das ja nicht dass diese
Regierung und auch mit verlobt meine
Person das einfach sofort schreibt
soweit jetzt zu der Frage von Ulrike
Herrmann in dem Papier ist festgehalten
worden dass es ein sozialen Ausgleich
gibt das heißt anders als die bisherige
Förderung auch in diesem Bereich also
wir haben im Moment ein Programm
aufgelegt für Wärmepumpen die über
verschiedene Stufen bis zu 40%
unterstützt werden ohne soziale das ist
Gießkanne wenn diese wollen das kriegt
der Millionär und das kriegt die
Rentnerinnen und Rentner wir schauen
nicht auf die Einkommenslage was wir
jetzt festgelegt haben ist wir schauen
auf die Einkommenslage und wir sorgen
für ein sozialen Ausgleich so dass wenn
eine Pflicht kommt die die Gasheizung
geht kaputt und dann muss sie
ausgetauscht werden zu einer Wärmepumpe
dass die unteren und mittleren Einkommen
das habe ich ja schon politisch gesagt
jedenfalls in der Phase solange die
Wärmepumpen teurer sind die werden wie
alles Solaranlagen und auch Immobilien
günstiger werden so unterstützt werden
dass sie nicht überfordert werden meine
Ansicht nach so unterstützt werden dass
sie die dass sie nicht drauf zahlen
dafür
überzeugt ihr das Frau Herrmann ich
meine wenn die Pflicht kommt war gerade
der entscheidende Halbsatz die Pflicht
kommt sagte Herbert gerade wenn die alte
kommt ja ab ja die kommt ab wann kommt
die wann kommt das die kommt ab nächsten
Jahr das heißt das heißt wenn die alte
Öl und Gasheizung jetzt sind wir genau
an dem Punkt auf den ich wollte die alte
Gasheizung geht kaputt dann kommt die
Pflicht die zu ersetzen durch was
Wärme also zwangsläufig aber ich glaube
man muss mal eine Sache sagen die ganz
wichtig ist äh die in der Diskussion
immer untergeht die Wärmepumpe ist an
sich ein super Geschäft die Wärmepumpe
ist effizienter als eine
Gasheizung weil es so ist dass man aus
einer Kilowattstunde Strom kann man drei
bis vier Kilowattstunden Wärme
produzieren
ist
bei der Wärmepumpe das ist ja der Trick
und das muss man glaube ich den Leuten
immer wieder erklären ist das geniale
eigentlich dass man die Wärme der Luft
oder vor allen Dingen auch die Wärme des
Bodens nutzt häufig erklärt genau das
einzige Problem an der Wärmepumpe ist
und deswegen gibt es diese ganzen
Debatten ist eigentlich ein super
Geschäft das die Anschaffungskosten
höher sind als die einer Gasheizung
das Prinzip Wärmepumpe bedeutet ja in
Wahrheit nichts anderes als wir
elektrifizieren Deutschland
identifizieren heizen ja und mit Hilfe
der Wärmepumpe über den Umweg Wärmepumpe
Hebeln wir sozusagen die verfügbare
Menge Strom eine Luftwärmepumpe hebelt
den um den Faktor 4 wenn man in die
Tiefe bohrt wahrscheinlich sogar Faktor
4,5 oder 5 das ist das was dann passiert
genau aber all das funktioniert ja nur
dann richtig gut wenn Strom erstens
günstig ist und wir alle wissen Strom in
Deutschland ist nicht günstig strom ist
teuer zweiter Punkt Wärmepumpe
funktioniert dann wenn wir in der Lage
sind gedämmte Fenster vorzuweisen beim
in der Lage sind unsere Dächer zu dämmen
und wenn wir drittens eine
Fußbodenheizung haben nichts von alledem
ist in unglaublich oder fast nichts von
alledem ist in unglaublich vielen
Bestandswohnungen der Fall und dazu
kommen diese hohen Energie und heißt in
dem Fall Strompreise deswegen noch mal
die Frage nach der sozialen Frage wie
soll das funktionieren herr Herbert wie
will eine Regierung das alles stimmen
das wird nicht funktionieren und jetzt
habe ich über die Handwerker die diese
vielen Fenster dämmen die Dächer dämmen
die Fußbodenheizungen einbauen die
Wärmepumpen einbauen über die habe ich
jetzt noch gar nicht gesprochen wo die
herkommen soll
also erst einmal das für
handwerkermangel haben überhaupt
Arbeitskräfte Mangel das ist so das gilt
auch für den Einbau einer neuen Öl oder
Gasheizung also das kann man nicht
wegreden die die eigentliche
Wachstumsbremse für die deutsche
Volkswirtschaft in der Zukunft werden
fehlende Arbeitskräfte sein egal
genau darf ich da immer noch mal ganz
kurz dazwischen natürlich auch ich weiß
genau dürfen sie sofort nur einmal ganz
kurz dazwischen gefragt sie sagen das
ist ein riesiges Problem jetzt geht
diese Gasheizung diese Ölheizung kaputt
und sie zwingen oder die Regierung sagt
jetzt ihr müsst das jetzt aber bitte
anders machen was mache ich denn wenn
ich diese Handwerker mir das jetzt
einbauen sollen schlicht oder greifend
gut das Problem entspricht dem wenn Sie
ein Gaskessel einbauen wollen würden ja
die Handwerker fehlen also fühlen Sie
auch bei dem Einbau eines Julia Gases
lass sozusagen in der Sache kein
Unterschied dass wir handwerkermangel
haben ist zuzugeben bitte warum ist der
Unterschied es gibt einen Unterschied
weil nur ich wenn man mit Verband
verwenden spricht mit Fachleuten spricht
dann sagen die maximal 20% derer die
heute Gas und Ölheizungen einbauen also
der Installateure kennen sich auch mit
Wärmepumpen wirklich aus und dann im
Berufsschulen werden nach wie vor Leute
ausgebildet die sich mit Öl und
Gasheizungen auskennen das ist ein
großes Problem
das sind aber ich will nicht
wortklauberer Stein Herr Lanz aber jetzt
sind wir doch sehr im Detail und das
würde ich dann gerne auch mal abarbeiten
wenn sie sagen wir haben keine
Handwerker haben Sie Recht oder ein
handwerkermangel wenn sie das da ist
kein Unterschied zwischen Ölheizung und
Wärmepumpen handwerkermangel 0 ist 0
wenn sie sagen wir haben Handwerker aber
sie sind noch nicht ausgebildet genug es
ist eine leicht andere Herausforderung
also müssen wir sie ausbilden das
passiert unter Hochdruck und danach wir
haben ja früh angefangen das war gleich
eine der ersten Amtshandlungen in meinem
ja die haben mit dem Beschluss schon vor
einem Jahr gefasst die die
Karbonisierung und dann im Bereich
voranzubringen mit den
handwerksausbildungsbetrieben und den
Handwerkskammern gesprochen die werden
also gerade ausgebildet ich glaube also
dass das gelingen wird dass wir die
Handwerker die wir haben
auch so ausbilden können denn das
passiert ja gerade dass sie Wärmepumpen
einbauen sehen Sie wir haben im letzten
Jahr über 200.000 Wärmepumpen eingebaut
von der Hälfte kommend das haben wir
auch Handwerker gemacht die davor noch
nicht ausgebildet waren das ist
natürlich jetzt der nächste Schritt von
200 auf 400 oder vielleicht 500.000 zu
kommen aber wir sind ja da ist ja auch
schon Erfahrung gewachsen das halte ich
also für lösbar zweiter Punkt in der
Regel wird es oder häufig wird es eine
Wärmepumpe sein aber es muss nicht eine
Wärmepumpe sein denn gerade im
innerstädtischen Bereich ist eigentlich
das effizient des System ein
fernwärme-system das ist das was
Skandinavien ganz stark gemacht hat man
betrachtet nicht dass einzelne Haus oder
das einzelne in diesem Fall Mietshaus
sondern man versucht die Häuser
anzuschließen und ein gemeinsames System
dass ich dann aus verschiedenen Quellen
speisen kann warum ist das ein Vorteil
für die Kommunen weil die Quellen sich
gegenseitig unterstützen können das kann
eine großwärmepumpe sein das kann
Biomasse sein es kann
Strom zu Wärme sein was immer gerade
verfügbar ist immer das günstigste wird
genommen wenn die Kommunen solche Pläne
haben und diese Pläne belegen können
also nicht so ja wollen wir mal
irgendwann machen wir wissen aber auch
nicht dann werden die verbrochenen
Verbraucher von der Pflicht sofort zu
dekarbonisieren entbunden also sie
müssen dann keine Wärmepumpe einbauen
sondern sie können sich für den Übergang
gebrauchten Öl oder Gaskessel oder auch
einen neuen Öl oder Gaskessel besorgen
aber es muss dann eben dann passieren
dann zur Frage der Gebäude Sanierung es
ist natürlich trivialerweise richtig die
geschützter die Gebäudehülle ist umso
umso weniger Energie brauche ich umso
effektiver wird Energie eingesetzt aber
es ist nicht richtig dass man nur passiv
Häuser also oder sehr gut trainierte
Häuser mit Wärmepumpen warm kriegt denn
ich weiß auf Skandinavien der Gebäu
Zwischenstand ähnlich das geht schon
falls es aber nicht geht also falls es
sehr schlecht trainierte Häuser sind
oder es wird sehr kalt gibt es auch eine
Lösung denn man kann Wärmepumpen
kombinieren mit kleinen Gasbrennern
heißt also vom September bis Dezember
wenn das mal nicht so kalt ist läuft die
Wärmepumpe und wenn es dann in den
Wintermonaten Dezember Januar richtig
knackig wird springt der Gaskessel an
auch kein Problem dann ist der Anteil an
der erneuerbaren Energien immer noch bei
65 % sie haben mir gerade die
Wirkungsgrade geschrieben was ich also
sagen will ist mir ich bin in jeder
Hinsicht maximal pragmatisch jede Lösung
jede Übergangsfrist die hilft kann
genommen werden es geht hier nicht darum
eine Ideologie durchzudrücken worum es
geht ist eine Schubumkehr einzuleiten
nicht in diese Richtung die ganze Zeit
weiter zu laufen und wenn ich das mal
mit sagen darf mit Verlaub den
Bürgerinnen und Bürgern zu erzählen
investiert weiterhin Öl und Gasheizung
das ist günstiger Frau Hermann hat recht
das ist es nicht es ist ja längst
beschlossen dass der CO2-Preis steigen
wird und von der Sicherheitsfrage mal
ganz zu schweigen sie haben Recht der
Strom
treibt die Wärmepumpen an wenn ich jetzt
bei den Wärmepumpen bleibe aber den
erzeugen wir hier Gas und Öl importieren
wir das heißt die Unabhängigkeit aber
auch die Wertschöpfung in Deutschland
bleibt im eigenen Land das also das ist
der Unterschied und alle Schritte die
auf dem Weg dahin ist leichter machen
pragmatischer machen die können gegangen
werden es gibt da gibt es maximale
Flexibilität aber was was mich so ein
bisschen wie soll ich sagen
herausfordert ist zu sagen es könnte
schwierig werden denn das ist es ohne
Frage wir greifen sehr stark auf das
persönliche lebensverhältnis der
Bürgerinnen und Bürger zu das ist mir
klar dass man damit nicht populär wird
aber weil es schwierig wird packen das
mal beiseite das hat uns doch zu dieser
Haltung uns in den Schlamassel gebracht
indem wir uns teilweise befinden alles
dauert zu lange passiert gerade gar
nicht das einzige worin wir gut sind ist
große Pläne verkünden aber die Umsetzung
so naja würde ich sagen
dass das ist der eigentliche Unterschied
und der ist heute bestätigt worden
überzeugt den Unterschied wollen wir
machen überzeugt Sie Alexander also ich
werde keine installateurs-fach
Kenntnisse vortäuschen weil ich keine
habe kann da nur politisch drauf blicken
ja das meine ich und politisch also der
die grundfragestellung kann man in
ungedämmten Häusern mit einer Ölheizung
zu Klimaneutralität kommen da muss man
nicht der größte Öko unter der Sonne zu
sein um zu verstehen dass das nicht geht
also das politisch was passiert musste
war klar hätte auch eine andere
Regierung übrigens machen müssen so und
jetzt habe ich gesagt zum dritten Mal
das Versprechen seiner Koalitionspartner
dass sie seinen Weg mitgehen das kann
man sagen drücken wir alle die Daumen
dass es diesmal hält und das
Kleingedruckte kennen wir noch nicht
in dieser politischen Versuchsanordnung
ich meine das ist ja ein Thema wo die
Regierung eigentlich beruhigend auf die
Bevölkerung wirken müsste nämlich hier
ist ein Problem dass es unser Plan okay
aber die meisten Leute haben ja erst
davon erfahren durch den Streit in der
Regierung und es ist ja sogar ein ran
auf Gasheizung ein ausgelöst wo nach dem
Motto bauen wir jetzt noch schnell ein
ja so und ob das jetzt nach diesem
Koalitionsausschuss hält ähm schauen wir
mal okay um das Thema kurz noch
abzuschließen habe kamen sie eigentlich
mittlerweile rausgefinden gefunden wo
das Leck war um mal im Bild zu bleiben
wo war die undichte Stelle wer hat das
durchgesteckt
keine Ahnung
so übersichtlich wie sie Antworten haben
sie in der Ahnung was er der eigene
Laden wirklich keine Ahnung was die FDP
oder die RDS okay gut dann okay andere
Thema anderes Thema um das es heute auch
ging vielleicht kann das Robin Alexander
einmal kurz angeordnen autobahnprojekte
wie sehr hat sich das überrascht dass es
plötzlich um 144 Straßenbau Projekte
geht ich hatte zwischendurch noch eine
kleinere Tage gehört und 144 scheint mir
eine ganze Menge und hat ja gesehen als
die Parteivorsitzende von Herrn habix
Partei das vorgestellt hat
genau gesagt wir müssen jetzt auch
Straße priorisieren was die Grünen ja
nicht wollten aber daneben werden jetzt
Solaranlagen gebaut das scheint mir ein
sehr naheliegender Kompromiss zu sein
aber ich persönlich fand das findet es
richtig weil ich glaube es nicht
Illusion zu glauben dass man überhaupt
nicht mehr in die Straße investieren
muss und da haben die Grünen sich ein
Stück weit auf die anderen beiden
zugewicht wie haben sie das wahrgenommen
Frau Hermann ja also ich meine da muss
man jetzt mal sagen dass die FDP sich da
durchgesetzt hat und es also sozusagen
wenn man jetzt rein sachlich
argumentieren würde wäre es so dass man
sagen muss eigentlich darf man gar keine
Autobahn mehr bauen weil es langfristig
und mittelfristig so ist dass wir
weniger Autos haben müssen wenn die
Ökoenergie reichen soll in Deutschland
das sagen alle Studien dann müssen wir
runter von 50 Millionen Autos auf 30
Millionen Autos dann also man muss den
Verkehr eigentlich halbieren und wenn
man das klar hat dass man eigentlich den
Verkehr halbieren muss dann ist es
natürlich völliger Unsinn noch weitere
Autobahnen zu bauen jetzt kann ich aber
verstehen dass die Grünen keine Chance
hatten weil
da hat sich eindeutig die FDP
durchgesetzt aber dass sie sich
durchgesetzt hat liegt ja daran dass
auch die SPD auf dieser Seite ist weil
sie dann alle immer die Umfragen lesen
und die Umfragen zeigen eben dass die
Mehrheit der Deutschen an ihrem Auto
klebt die wollen Autobahnen die glauben
auch das ist ja das was die FDP sagt
übrigens auch ein Irrtum die FDP sagt ja
das haben sie auch genauso begründet ja
da gibt es Stau nicht das heißt dann
engpassstellen und um den Stau
aufzulösen müssen wir neue Autobahnen
bauen oder neue Streifen oder Spuren und
das ist jede
Untersuchung von
verkehrswissenschaftlern zeigt dass das
falsch ist also wenn man neue Autobahnen
baut dann hat man nicht weniger Stau
sondern mehr Verkehr so Robin Alexander
guckt gerade sehr
verschmerzverzert naja der Ferne ist
halber sollte man vielleicht sagen dass
es nicht
das ist nicht riesige neue Autobahn
geplant sind sondern einfach da wo man
Lücken schließen muss und man kann ja
der Meinung sein dass die Leute alle
viel weniger Auto fahren müssen aber die
Entschuldigung viel Glück dass den
Leuten so erklären aber die die
Projektion auf den Grundlage die ihre
Beschlüsse gemacht haben sagen die
Mobilität steigt dramatisch und die
Schiene kann sie obwohl sie ja die
Schiene soll viel stärker ausgebaut
werden als die Autobahn steht in dem
Papier kann nicht wirklich in das nicht
alleine auffangen können und dann finde
ich ist das eine pragmatische Lösung
wie haben sie das wahrgenommen aber ich
habe sie dieser Tage irgendwo gehört sie
sagten das kann auf gar keinen Fall die
Lösung sein dass wir jetzt wieder
anfangen ein Autobahn zu planen neue
Straßenbauprojekte vorantreiben wir
müssen runter vom Individualverkehr
warum jetzt doch
das war glaube ich jemand anderes aber
vielleicht habe ich es auch gesagt ich
bin noch nicht im Moment erinnerlich
aber
es geht um die dekarbonisierung das sind
die dualverkehrs aber ich finde auch es
ist eine pragmatische Lösung vielleicht
darf ich das kurz einordnen ja es ist
ein großes bahnpaket beschlossen worden
auch mit finanzieller Hinterlegung weil
die Lkw-Maut eine zusätzliche CO2-Abgabe
bekommen wird das wird dazu führen dass
ich der Schwerlastverkehr klimaneutral
aufstellen wird und Geld eingesammelt
wird das ganz wesentlich in die Bahn
geht das ist also sehr sehr wuchtig und
sehr gut dann ist es richtig zweitens ja
wir beschleunigen sehr viele
Infrastrukturprojekte
Brückensanierung Schienenausbau
Elektrifizierung von Schienen und auch
autobahnprojekte keine neuen es geht
nicht um Neubau sondern es geht um
sogenannte Engstellen Beseitigung also
vorhandene Autobahnen die repariert und
ausgeweitet werden müssen das eine
Verbreiterung der Fahrbahn aus einer
Liste die deutlich kleiner ist als die
Liste die wir Prozess mal beraten haben
da sich nicht um Neubauprojekte handelt
und die
engstellenbeseitigung
argumentierbar ist haben wir dem
zugestimmt das ist aber ohne Frage so
wie Frau Hermann und Herr Alexander
gesagt haben das war jetzt kein Wunsch
der Grünen oder von mir persönlich
sondern der FDP und der SPD und da sind
wir wie auch würde ich sagen bei den
Maßnahmen die im Verkehrsbereich
ergriffen worden nicht stolz drauf wir
haben das trotzdem jetzt mitgemacht weil
das nun zu dem Wesen von Kompromissen
gehört dass man auch Sachen mitmacht die
die andere Seite haben will denn der der
Hauptsinn neben den ganzen Detail
Aspekten und diesen ganzen wer gewinnt
und wer verliert Rätsel das jetzt wieder
losgeht ist doch das mal Probleme gelöst
werden dass wir und deswegen hat sie
auch so lange gedauert
dass wir
handlungsfähig sind und Sachen mal
wegmachen also Weg entscheiden und jetzt
umsetzen und uns den nächsten Sachen
zuwenden also da haben wir uns auch sehr
schon in einer staatsbürgerlichen
Verantwortung gefunden die jetzt nicht
nur auf das einzelne Teilprojekt schaut
sondern sagt
wir müssen jetzt hier Vorankommen also
springen wir auch mal über unseren
Schatten in diesem Fall würde ich sagen
es ist ein Schätzchen was ich jetzt
nicht schlimm was da beschlossen wurde
aber natürlich ist es richtig nicht der
grüne Wunsch gewesen so wie wir uns von
anderen Stellen wo wir an anderen
Stellen Sachen bekommen haben die jetzt
vielleicht nicht auf der Wunschliste von
FDP und SPD standen aber das nennt man
normal gemeinsam das Regieren und
Kompromisse der einige gewinnt der
andere verliert also für uns ist das
jetzt im Augenblick nicht zu beurteilen
wie immer diese 144 irgendwas Stellen
sind und wie viele Autobahnkilometer da
faktisch eine neue Spur bekommen das
werden wir dann ja vielleicht noch sehen
wenn das detailpapier kommt aber ich
glaube es gibt ein Problem bei dieser
Ausgleichsrechnung also diesen
politischen Druck unter dem die Grünen
standen kann ich total nachvollziehen
das Land will Autobahn FDP und SPD
wollen das und jetzt wird ja aber gesagt
gut dafür haben wir die Schiene gerettet
und die kriegt jetzt 45 Milliarden bis
2027 das sind ja jetzt nur noch vier
Jahre das kann man dann so durchrechnen
okay das sind dann ungefähr 10
Milliarden pro Jahr das ist ja erstmal
eine stattliche Summe was ich überhaupt
nicht verstehe ist wie diese 10
Milliarden zustande kommen sollen durch
diese CO2-Abgabe bei der Lkw-Maut weil
ich nachgeguckt habe die Lkw-Maut im
Augenblick bringt insgesamt vielleicht
ist die Zahl falsch aber das ist so dass
das öffentlich kuriert 7,6 Milliarden
wenn man jetzt äh 10 Milliarden
zusätzlich pro Jahr da einnehmen will
dann würde das ja heißen dass man die
Lkw-Maut mehr als verdoppelt jetzt will
meine Frage an sie steht das in den
Papier dass man die Lkw-Maut mehr als
verdoppelt weil es ja auch noch so ist
dass nur 80% dieser CO2-Abgabe für den
Bahnverkehr verwendet werden also müsste
man ja eigentlich dann diese ganze
CO2-Abgabe sagen wir mal bei 12
Milliarden ansetzen und im augenbringt
die LKW macht nur 7,6 Milliarden also
das kann mir gar nicht vorstellen dass
die FDP dem zugestimmt hat aber
vielleicht irre ich mich da ja
nie Stich mehr als verdoppeln sondern es
werden ungefähr 6 Milliarden mehr
eingenommen pro Jahr durch eine
CO2-Abgabe auf die Lkw-Maut also die das
hängt ist ja jetzt entfernungs- oder
kilometerabhängig keiner kann es genauso
sagen ob es 5,9 oder 6,1 Milliarden
werden aber die Schätzung ist nach dem
bisherigen Verkehrsaufkommen ungefähr 6
Milliarden von denen dann 80%, 5 in die
in die in die Schiene gehen werden sie
haben aber recht die Lücke ist sogar
noch größer also die kalkulierte Lücke
beim schienennetzausbau beträgt 45
Milliarden nur die Lücke ist ja schon
auch es gibt ja schon Geld dafür das
wird also nicht voll geschlossen aber
trotzdem ich meine das ist eine neue
Finanzierung die eine ökologische
Lenkungswirkung hat und jetzt in die
Schiene geht viel mehr also ehrlich das
finde ich das schon da bin ich erst
eigentlich eher überrascht dass das
geeint werden konnte weil das schon
einen massiver Schritt ist aber das doch
irgendwie komisch dass man sagt man gibt
45 Milliarden aus aber man hat praktisch
dann am Ende nur 20 Milliarden
es gibt noch andere Möglichkeiten
beziehungsweise Ideen wie Gelder
aufgebracht werden da bin ich bereits
aber noch nicht reingeschrieben die noch
nicht endverhandelt ja Robin Alexander
und erstmal sollen ja gerne ausgegeben
werden also an der stelle ich gucke noch
mal auf die Planungs- und
genehmigungsphasen also wenn wir das
schaffen 20 Milliarden auch wirklich zu
verbauen also dass jemand das Geld als
Rechnung gestellt bekommt dann können
wir es gar nicht unzufrieden sein
trotzdem wir noch mehr notwendig ist wir
finden noch mehr ist natürlich super das
haben wir jetzt noch nicht geeint aber
vor dem nach dem Koalitionsausschuss ist
vor dem vor der Arbeit der Koalition
sage ich mal probieren Alexander
ich glaube Herbeck ist hier in der
schwierigen Position weil nach drei
Tagen Ringen mit FDP und SPD hat er
jetzt noch so ein bisschen in der grüne
koalitionsverhandlung weil Frau Hermann
hat ein anderes Bild vom Frau Verkehr
Frau Hermann hat die Idee dass wir alle
ganz ganz viel weniger Auto fahren
müssen und am besten keine Autos
besitzen sollen und die Idee der Ampel
ist ja nicht jedem sein Auto wegzunehmen
sondern umzustellen auf Autos die mit
ihm Mobilität fahren und wenn man diesen
Ansatz hat dann kann man natürlich
solche Sachen machen und deshalb glaube
ich ist das auch ein Konflikt und da ist
vorher man ja nicht die einzige im
Grünen Spektrum die auf diesem Trip ist
Fridays for future Kalorien Smart heute
abend irgendwie getwittert und sagte er
im Jahr 2023 also in Richtung Robert
habe jetzt wenn im Jahr 2023 noch das
Wort Straßen Neubau und Klimaschutz in
den Mund nimmt der kann direkt aufhören
von Klimaschutz zu sprechen
ja nochmal es ist ja kein Neubau also im
Sinne Erweiterung
Straße Stärken darum geht also das
Signal ist ja klar
wir haben was wir beschlossen haben ist
ähnlich wie bei anderen
Infrastrukturprojekten dass der bei den
Engpässen der
überragende öffentliche Bedarf
festgestellt wurde das heißt in einem
Abwägungsprozess mit anderen Gütern kann
schneller geplant und dann
logischerweise schneller gebaut werden
noch einmal dass ich es nicht mein
Herzensprojekt da will ich gar nicht
daran vorbei reden aber es ist jetzt
nicht Neubau die kommen nur etwas
schneller diese Projekte wenn sie denn
kommen und zweitens ist diese Liste von
den 144 Teilstücken
Teilstücke sind dann immer Abschnitte
zwischen Ausfahrten kann man ungefähr
über den Daumen ja rechnen wie weit die
sind und was das an Kilometern sein kann
daran gebunden dass die Länder ist
wollen das heißt wir haben eine
definierte und auch abschließende Liste
beschlossen das ist eine Liste die
vorliegt und jetzt müssen die Länder in
denen in deren Bundesländern diese
Teilstücke sind sagen von dieser
Regelung wollen wir gebrauchen machen
sie müssen sich also bei beim Volk ein
bisschen oder seinen nachgeordneten
Behörden melden ich gehe nicht davon aus
dass alle Teilstücke darunter fallen und
dass das dann passiert denn teilweise
ist es wahrscheinlich wohl angebracht
sorgsam und nicht zu schnell abzuwägen
da mögen ja andere Schutzgüter noch
Berücksichtigung finden gar nicht nur
jetzt Artenschutz oder Umweltschutz
sondern
Anwohner werden vielleicht gehört werden
wollen oder die Industrie hat noch
debattenbedarf ob das vierspurig oder
sechsspurig werden soll was immer einem
vorstellen mag die Welt das große Bund
das heißt also eine flexible Lösung auf
eine abschließende Liste klar viele
grüne werden nicht klatschen und sagen
super danke dass ihr das durchgekriegt
hat aber man muss jetzt sehen was da
insgesamt steht wir haben auch eine
Beschleunigung für die Genehmigung von
Umwelt und Naturschutzgebieten
reingeschrieben da nehme ich an jetzt
wird die er die FDP und Christian dürr
debattenbedarf haben das ist ja dann
quasi ökologisch Infrastruktur und so
haben wir relativ kreativ finde ich
Ausgleich gefunden zwischen den Wünschen
der verschiedenen Partner und noch
einmal wenn ich jetzt wenn mal wenn ich
mal kurz das aufrechnen wer gewinnt wer
verliert wird ausgegeben etwas bekommen
ist ein ist ein Naturschutzgebiete viel
wert wie eine Autobahnraststätte oder
weniger wenn das mal kurz weg geht was
wir gemacht haben ist
Probleme zu lösen die sich hier etwas
aufgestaut haben auch verknotet oder
verknüppelt haben und das ist das
entscheidende und deswegen ist auch
entscheidend dass die innere Haltung ist
wir wollen Probleme lösen wir springen
über unser einen Schatten wenn ich also
da darf ich mal
so zusammenfassen im Grunde bin ich
stolz auf das was die Grünen gemacht
haben und auch bei mir bei den Projekten
wo wir nicht der Meinung sind dass sie
nach dass sie notwendig sind mein Stolz
richtet sich nicht darauf dass wir ganz
viel für erneuerbare Energien geholt
haben sondern dass wir in der Lage waren
der anderen Seite auch ihren Raum zu
geben und ich hoffe dass die anderen ist
genauso sehen wie oft war es denn diesen
Verhandlungen zwei gegen einen also SPD
und FDP gegen sie
ist doch egal aber ich hätte noch mal
eine Regierung und das haben wir jetzt
haben wir
bitte so oft
wirklich wir sind eine Regierung wir
haben das sieht man ja es gab viel zu
besprechen und viel zu reden das haben
wir es geeint und jetzt setzen wir es
gemeinsam um das ist aber wirklich das
interessanter bei diesem
Koalitionsausschuss weil alle dachten ja
vorher oh die FDP muss das lagerwechseln
die FDP muss jetzt mit rot grün und die
sind sich so ein über ihren Schatten
springen und in diesem
koalitionsverschluss war es eher so die
Grünen haben mit einer rot-gelben Front
gerungen und die Grünen waren die die
Zähnen und Klauen Auspacken mussten um
ihr Zeug zu sichern also das ist doch
zeigen das ist nicht mehr dieses linke
Lager und einer kommt irgendwie aus der
Mitte sondern es ist eher ein Lager das
sehr forciert beim Klimaschutz ist und
ein Lager das sagt oh ab wegen abwägen
abwägen